[Música]
eu to curioso
quantos de vocês aqui do auditório já
ficaram uma pessoa com deficiência
2 é pouco né
uma pesquisa inglesa revelou que apenas
7% das pessoas sem deficiência já se
relacionou com deficiência
não existem dados sobre o brasil mas eu
imagino que a proporção deverá ser mais
ou menos a mesma
se a gente parar pra pensar que segundo
o último censo 2010 cerca de 24% da
população brasileira têm algum tipo de
deficiência
mas as pessoas aqui dentro já deveriam
ter beijado no mímino comigo por exemplo
mas não é isso que acontece e não
acontece pela maneira como as pessoas
como esse com deficiência ainda são
vistas pela sociedade
já perguntaram por uma garota se ela
está ficando comigo por qualidade e por
falar nisso
uma vez eu estava andando pela banana no
clube quando um casal me olhou com cara
de pedro em 1 comentou com o outro
coitadinho dele sem parar de andar
eu respondi à tardinha o carro amba
essa é uma frase que eu uso muito e ela
diz muito sobre mim mas na versão com um
palavrão não é pessoal
não acho que minha vida seja mais
difícil para eu ter uma difícil eu
trabalho
moro sozinho pratica escalada e namora
há três anos ou seja como qualquer um de
vocês
a vantagem de não precisar ingerir uma
gota de álcool sequer perde de vez em
quando acharem que eu estou andando
bêbado pela rua
eu não acho que tenha sido mais difícil
mas minha vida foi assim diferente 30
anos até se por exemplo eu fui
alfabetizado usando uma máquina de
escrever enquanto os meus amigos que
vinham com lapsos melhor melhor não sei
sei que todos ficavam loucos para
digitar rolava até uma disputa para
saber quem quer ser o escolhido do dia
tamos a máquina no fim do recreio e eu
bom eu adorava não fazer aulas de
caligrafia a minha letra sempre foi a
melhor da turma e acompanhado do tec tec
da matur eu comecei a passar para o
papel a as histórias que alimentava uma
delas eu salvei o submarino dos
tentáculos de um polvo e das presas em
uma baleia orca
em outra a maior atração do circo que
passou pela cidade
foi uma tartaruga trapezista o tempo
passou e eu continuo contando histórias
só tem invés de sair do papel com a
imaginação de quem lê
hoje elas ainda o editor de texto em vão
para as telas de cinema e tv sobre o
comentarista e o meu primeiro longa
finalidade 2018 é uma autobiografia eu
aposto que você está se perguntando qual
o nome do filme meu nome é daniel não é
isso a gente já sabe qual o nome do
filme
então o título do filme é meu nome é
daniel
essa confusão gerou piano interno da
equipe e aconteceu em quase todos os
festivais por onde o fundo passou no
brasil na holanda na colômbia e até na
austrália
no fechado signe meu nome é daniel fez
parte de uma mostra em pelo menos um
membro da equipe criativa dos filmes
tinha algum tipo de deficiência
o festival também terá um painel com
alguns dos realizadores
durante o debate um roteirista
australiano fez uma observação muito
pertinente
segundo ele a deficiência é geralmente
usada com o elemento edificante vai
ajudar o personagem principal atingir
seu objetivo em vez de ser retratada de
maneira honesta em real é um velho
estereótipo da superação é a pessoa com
deficiência vista como um ser elevado
o enviado de deus para tornar aquela
família melhor alguém que em sinal para
os outros só porque de segunda a sexta
levanta da cama e café da manhã e saiba
trabalhar assim como os olhares e
comentários de penna este lugar de super
herói sempre me incomodou mas eu não
sabia muito bem porque aos poucos eu fui
percebendo que para a maioria das
pessoas tem uma deficiência é uma coisa
ruim
se você trabalha e joga bola vai ao
cinema sozinho
mesmo tendo uma essência você é
excepcional porque só sendo um super
herói é fazer tudo isso com esse corpo
mal acabado
certa vez uma pessoa chegou perto de mim
colocou a mão no meu ombro e disse você
é uma inspiração para mim cara toda vez
que eu tomo lado meio chateado com a
amiga
eu lembro de você eu fiquei meio sem
ganhar sabendo um sorriso de canto de
boca e sair de pé
depois me arrependi
eu devia ter falado quer dizer que toda
vez que você tá na merda você lembra de
mim
ou então pensa algo do tipo
não posso reclamar da vida olha como
poderia ser pior se eu tivesse uma
deficiência
vamos combinar uma coisa vocês nunca
mais vão repassar para o grupo da
família aquela imagem integrado tinha
então se não disputa uma prova de
atletismo acompanhada do texto
qual vai ser sua desculpa para não
tentar mais uma vez hoje há também não
pode compartilhar o vídeo da minha
palestra e dizer que sou um exemplo de
superação oque continuam no assunto há
alguns anos atrás uma matéria telejornal
local do rio de janeiro disse que uma
quadrilha havia sido presa após assaltar
um ônibus até aí nenhuma novidade mas no
final da chamada apresentadora completou
vocês não vão acreditar o líder do grupo
é não cadeirante assim mesmo bem
sensacionalista
é tanta incapacidade ou heroísmo que nem
o direito de ser ladrão a gente tem
temos que mudar urgentemente à maneira
com nós pessoas com deficiência são os
mesmos e eu digo pessoa com deficiência
porque ela tem dito que a licença que eu
tenho não miller sin
ela só mais uma das minhas
características
faz parte de wilson a começar a mudar
esta cultura capacita precisamos
aparecer somam cerca de 1 milhão de
pessoas no mundo a maior das minorias
no entanto ainda somos mais tão bem
representado na mídia e nos meios de
comunicação
geralmente quando aparecemos em jornais
e na tv
acabamos ser tratadas pelo olhar de
pessoas sem deficiência
eu fui o primeiro diretor de cinema com
deficiência brasileiro a fazer um longa
metragem sobre a própria vida mas eu só
tive noção da importância disso quando
depois de uma das exibições do meu nome
é daniel um jovem estudante de cinema
pediu a palavra no debate e diz que o
documentário tinha dado várias idéias e
caminhos para mim que ele está falando
sobre a sua vida
sim ele também tinha uma deficiência
representatividade importa e muito nada
sobre nós sem nós
ninguém sabe o que a gente realmente
livre antes de coitadinho heróis somos
pessoas e por isso nós mesmos precisamos
contar nossa história dizer qual é o meu
andar nesse mundo sendo visto como um
ser estranho na escola no trabalho e nas
relações da etapa muito tempo eu achei
que nem aquele ficar comigo por causa da
deficiência e olha levei um tempo em
alguns foras para perceber que isso é
uma besteira
hoje eu sei que se tiver alguma questão
em relação ao que tenho é que me
encontrar
vou me dar uma chance a alguns anos eu
marcar um encontro com uma garota que eu
conheci um aplicativo de relacionamento
mas eu nem sempre dizia com uma
deficiência e acho que ela não sabia ela
teve um toque com a minha camisa e
quando eu cheguei no lugar marcado eu
não encontrei desconfia que ela foi
embora quando me viu durante a montagem
do meu nome é daniel surgiu a ideia para
um novo projeto estou produzindo um
filme onde homens e mulheres
intransitáveis e héteros com diversos
tipos de deficiência sobre sexualidade e
suas experiências afetivas uma das
personagens contou que depois de se
casar
o primeiro questionamento que surgiu foi
com ela acontece frequentemente acharem
que parceiros namoradas são nossos
amigos
irmãs ou então como o botão com a gente
por caridade por pena outra entrevistada
disse que após apresentar a namorada à
família teve que terminar o
relacionamento pois sua mãe falou que
nenhum homem aquele namorar uma pessoa
como ela
hoje essa mesma mulher é uma das
organizadoras da parada lgbt de são
paulo
um terceiro personagem o ator e
deficiente visual rodou sua primeira vez
foi com o colega de profissão no palco
de teatro entre quatro paredes e também
fora dela em pessoas com deficiência
fazendo coisas que vocês nem imagino
então eu vou deixar dito vai ter filme
feito por pessoas com deficiência sim
nós dirigimos descrevemos atuamos como
sushi
escalamos surfamos criamos histórias
sonhos e soluções que vocês também
nós estudamos pegamos o ônibus e
qualificamos temos troska a gente não
vai para a invisibilidade não é mais uma
opção pra gente
obrigado
[Aplausos]